aerologic geht die pandemie in diesem
sommer in diesen monaten zu ende
das kann ich ihnen aus meiner sicht noch
niemand sicher sagen aber wir haben im
moment ein paar annahmen wenn wir die
genau weiterverfolgen dann gibt es
glaube ich eine berechtigte hoffnung
aber im moment denke ich überwiegt noch
das thema das wir vorsichtig sein müssen
und genau hinschauen müssen was sich in
unseren krankenhäusern letztendlich
abspielt das ist der entscheidende
parameter das machen wir ja sowieso aber
das prinzip hoffnung das haben sie auch
noch mal betont der hologic das ist ja
das war es auch ihre ministerpräsident
plötzlich seit einigen tagen macht er
wiese ihr gesundheitsminister macht
heute noch das gegenteil in der bild am
sonntag auf seite eins die schlagzeile
omikron ist nicht das ende warum
ich glaube karl lauterbach hat heute in
einem interview in der bild am sonntag
deutlich gemacht dass wir möglicherweise
durch die maßnahmen die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben diese omnicom band
möglicherweise zu einem nikon hügel
führen können und von daher sehe ich
auch ordnung genau wie hologic aber wir
haben auch immer noch eine erhöhte zahl
gerade in der risikogruppe der über
60-jährigen geimpft sind das
möglicherweise zu krankenhaus
belastungen führt warum bin ich auch wie
er heute check noch vorsichtig was die
nächsten tage vielleicht auch die
nächsten ein zwei wochen angeht aber ich
möchte auch unterstreichen es gibt
hoffnung und karl lauterbach hat es ja
auch gesagt wir haben die chance von
einer pandemischen lage in eine
endemische lage zu kommen in diesem jahr
in diesen monaten in diesem sommer davor
ich glaube das werden die nächsten
wochen zeigen aber ich glaube im
hinblick wenn draußen auch die
temperaturen wärmer werden kann dies
gelingen von einer pandemischen in eine
endemische lage zu kommen es gibt aber
noch unsicherheiten da muss man auch
ehrlich sein aber ich glaube das kann
gelingt es gibt im moment noch diese
beiden lager die die ganz klar sagen ja
wir sind jetzt kurz vor diesem übergang
in die mmi wir sind kurz davor
rauszukommen aus der pandemie wozu
zählen eigentlich sie hätte bei der fdp
das weiß man im moment bei so vielen
fragen in dieser krise nicht wo steht
eigentlich die fdp also geht die
pandemie zu ende aus ihrer sicht ja oder
nein
wir sind grundsätzlich natürlich
optimistisch immer als liberaler aber
wir sind auch vorsichtig ist doch klar
wir haben bei der delta variante
deutlich gemacht dass wir bei den
massnahmen des bundes und der länder auf
wirksamkeit setzen die maßnahmen sollte
sich nicht gut in der zeitung an hören
sind sondern sie sollten wirksam gegen
das virus seien das gleiche betrifft
jetzt mikron auch da geht es um
wirksamkeit und wenn jetzt
großbritannien sozusagen den ausblick
gibt das ist besser wird dann hoffen wir
das natürlich auch für deutschland
zurzeit haben wir guten maßnahmenkatalog
sie auch in der ab der koalition
abgestimmt der offensichtlich
funktioniert auf dem weg sollten wir
weiter gehen vorsichtig bleiben aber
auch optimistisch sein erleben wir frau
stimmte das ende dieser pandemie für das
wäre fast zu schön um wahr zu sein ich
hoffe es ich hoffe es wirklich weil er
nicht nur das infektionsgeschehen haben
dass wir beobachten jeden tag beobachten
müssen sondern wir haben natürlich auch
eine gewisse gesellschaftliche
stimmungslage die uns auch politisch
immer mehr zu schaffen macht also die
frage welche maßnahmen wir anwenden wie
sie wirken und ob sie verhältnismäßig
sind die muss eigentlich mehr denn je
gestellt werden das erstaunliche an
dieser diskussion an der antwort auf die
frage geht die pandemie zu ende in kürze
ist ja dass jetzt dieser optimismus
dieser hoffnung ausgerechnet von den
virologen kommen die ja vielleicht am
konservativsten am vorsichtigsten waren
in der vergangenheit unter anderem vom
chef virologen der berliner charité von
christian drosten
so in diesen endemischen zustand das
erwarten wir schon den werden wir bis
ende des jahres schon entweder erreicht
haben oder wir sind praktisch da sie
sind praktisch da klaus stöhr top
virologen geht die pandemie also bald zu
ende also das ende der pandemie war am
anfang schon klar wie es zum schluss
dann sein wird aber man trifft ja nicht
aus einem dunklen raum durch eine tür
dann ins helle und dann ist man in der
in dem i das ist ein gleitender übergang
an dem gleitenden übergang heißt es
immer noch jetzt zwei bis drei millionen
ungeimpfte über 60 jährige noch relativ
viele andere die auch vielleicht noch
nicht die gesamte
spektrum abgearbeitet haben also es
dauert schon noch ein bisschen aber wir
wissen jetzt wie die nächsten monate
nicht verlaufen werden und im frühjahr
sommer dann wird es sehr entspannt haben
das schon alle verstanden in der politik
ihrem eindruck nach dass das zu ende
geht dass wir daraus können jetzt
langsam mit vorsicht aus der pandemie
aber dass das licht am ende des tunnels
zu sehen es haben das schon alle
verstanden oder machen wir noch die
politik von gestern
überschätzen sie mich das kann ich ihnen
nicht sagen aber was man sieht ist das
ein gewisser realität sind jetzt
zunehmend einzieht ich glaube auch
diejenigen die sehr verängstigt waren
oder sich vielleicht nicht an die
richtigen ratgeber gehalten haben sehen
jetzt schon dass die war vom anfang der
pandemie schon klare
übergangsphase zum ende der pandemie
wenn also sehr viele antikörper haben
wir das juristisch adaptiert hat dass
die jetzt einsetzt und dass man jetzt
endlich mal auch die rationalität waren
muss und man ein bisschen auch über den
tellerrand gucken aus dem manchmal
paralleluniversum dass deutschland
darstellen was die panini bekämpfung
betrifft aber die die die stellungnahme
mit dem gespräch vorher waren ja schon
ganz klar ich glaube schon dass die
meisten erkannt haben in welche richtung
es geht aber die vorsicht das stimmt
mich völlig zu ist auch jetzt ganz
wichtig wie wird denn sie haben gerade
von der übergangsphase gesprochen herr
stöhr wie wird in dieser übergang
aussehen also womit müssen wir noch wie
lange ungefähr rechnen hat den nächsten
zwei bis drei wochen wird sicherlich
eine unsicherheit geben wie hoch die
incident steigen wird aber man sollte
nicht wie ein kaninchen auf die schlange
dann auf die internet schauen sondern in
die haut oft die hospitalisierung traten
auch wenn die stückchen hinterherlaufen
und auch mal sehen was in den anderen
ländern los ist dort hat sich das ja
abgespaltet die schere geht auf die
auslizensierung bleibt die horizontal
oder fällt sogar aber das müssen wir
beobachten das ist richtig nächsten zwei
bis drei wochen danach wird durch die
sehr starke durchleuchtung die dann
leider einsetzen wird kann man nicht
abwenden werden sehr viele menschen sich
die natürliche immunität holen die wird
obendrauf gepflanzt auf die
immunisierung hoffentlich bei den
meisten die sich dann auch wirklich am
impfen lassen und das zusammen das paket
impfung plus infektion danach wird zum
langanhaltenden immunschutz führen dann
wird man auch nicht noch mal pusten
müssen das dritte 415 6 siebte mal
sondern im herbst dann sicherlich den ob
man die über 60-jährigen nochmal
impfangebot machen wird im sommer über
denke ich finde eine impfung nicht mehr
notwendig sein danke herzlich an den top
virologen klaus stöhr hier in den
richtigen fragen frau schimke wenn wir
das hören nochmal meine frage ist dann
die politik im grunde ihrer zeit
hinterher im moment noch naja also die
worte von herrn stöhr sind ja immer
nicht nur erfrischend sondern auch sehr
erhellend und wenn ein biologe wie er
sagt dass wir in deutschland doch zu
wenig realitätssinn haben und jetzt
endlich mal davon etwas mehr auch in der
politik eingang hält dann ist das doch
ein sehr eine sehr deutliche botschaft
und um ihre frage zu beantworten ja ich
würde mir manchmal wünschen dass wir
näher an der realität sind mit unseren
entscheidungen mit unseren abwägungen
ich meine wir reden jetzt über ein ende
der pandemie auf der einen seite und auf
der anderen seite um die einführung
einer impfpflicht also bitte wie soll
ich das jemandem erklären in diesem land
ich kann es nicht das tun wir gleich
ausgiebig holetschek zunächst an sie die
frage nach dieser übergangsphase die
auch herr stöhr gerade angesprochen hat
ihr ministerpräsident der schwingt jetzt
der leiter den kurswechsel ein der
spricht von freiheit wer nimmt nicht
mehr das wort team vorsicht in den mund
sondern spricht vom team augenmaß als
der sucht nach diesem realitätssinn den
jetzt frau schimke gerade beschrieben
hat was bedeutet das konkret für die
bürger also wo sehen die jetzt dann mehr
freiheit mehr augenmaß
lassen sich vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz einordnen damit wir nicht vergessen
wo wir herkommen vor ein paar wochen
werden in bayern eine belegung der
intensivbetten stationen von über 1000
wir haben menschen ab verlegen müssen
mit dem kleeblatt system in andere
bundesländer wofür ich ausdrücklich
dankbar war und haben gesehen wie
schwierig und wie schnell unser system
an die grenze kommt aber das wird
deswegen glauben müssen wir einfach ich
mag justieren dass man muss es aber man
muss es einfach noch mal sagen man muss
es doch einfach mal sagen dürfen um
jetzt auch zu verstehen wo sind wir
jetzt willkommen aus der delta wir haben
nikon mit einer niedrigeren krankheit
schwere hoffentlich einer niedrigen
belegung der intensivstationen deswegen
ist vorsicht und augenmaß kein
widerspruch sondern es sind beide seiten
einer medaille die man anwenden kann und
wenn wir jetzt die chance haben beim
recall anders aus zu steuern dann wollen
wir das auch tun ja nur deswegen
und genau hinschauen dass dann die
bürger
ja wir haben ja jetzt maßnahmen
getroffen die glaube ich wirken das
müssen wir zur kenntnis nehmen werden am
24 januar eine weitere
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten konferenz haben die
ja dann noch mal auf grund einer
expertenmeinung die weitere lage
beurteilt und daraus wird ein
abwägungsprozess entstehen wo kann man
mehr zu lassen zb kultur ein großes und
wichtiges thema eine diskussion gerade
über die kapazitäten und wo wird man
weiter vorsichtig sein müssen wir werden
auch weiter die maske brauchen also wir
werden jetzt nicht unmittelbar von einem
tag auf den anderen einen systemwechsel
haben aber ich glaube wir haben
parameter die mehr möglich machen und
wir müssen schauen dass die menschen
nach wie vor zum impfen gehen das ist
für mich unbestritten verstehe ja aber
freiheiten zum beispiel im kulturbereich
mehr menschen mehr zuschauer sagt jetzt
klaus holetschek bayerns
gesundheitsminister hürde das heißt die
csu überholt die fdp jetzt locker mal in
sachen freiheiten
sehen sie es mir nach ein bisschen
lachen also die letzten diskussionen der
letzten monate markus söder waren ja
teilweise absurd die waren ja absurd
markus söder hat sich hingestellt und
wollte am liebsten alles dichtmachen
möglicherweise inklusive schulschließung
das war unverantwortlich sagte das in
einer deutlichkeit was der bayerische
ministerpräsidenten monaten geleistet
hat und deswegen bin ich froh wenn man
muss sich sorgen gemacht das war als
hardware leider monaten schon öfter von
ihm gehört aber aber aber
nichtsdestotrotz mit verlaub das was wir
im november dezember von ihm gehört
haben mit dem thema epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite der
instrumentenkasten eben viel zu wenig
war zwar nie zu wenig
freiheitseinschränkung er wollte in
richtung lockdown gehen aber erst in
drei tagen hatte die opposition die
augen sagt nadine jahreswechsel macht er
hat sich jetzt zu einem
das freut mich mit mir hat noch geändert
wird eins wichtig das darf kein
politischer move gewesen sein sondern
wenn wir uns jetzt darauf einigen das
augenmaß maß und mitte dass das wieder
geht in der panini bekämpfung dann wäre
ich sehr sehr froh und wenn markus söder
und auch die bayerische stadt die
regierung sich auf diesem weg macht dann
wäre das gut die letzten monate sprechen
da bände wenn das jetzt besser wird dann
freut mich das als fdp politiker
sind ja in der vergangenheit ganz anders
war und jetzt tatsächlich offenbaren
kurs schwimmen aber bereits jetzt laufen
sie denn aber sie sollten sich jetzt mit
der fdp der noch festzelt an dem neuen
team vorsicht
auch wenn verladen sie sind gleich drei
ohne jack
early
check gerne gleich dazu wenn sie
rechtfertigen wollen was herr söder die
letzten monate so von sich gegeben hat
aber unabhängig davon ein maß und mitte
augenmaß und natürlich
verhältnismäßigkeit der maßnahmen ich
habe einst auch in dieser sendung vor
etwa einem monat gesagt damals mit herr
blume zusammen von der csu also ich habe
es gesagt jetzt anders gesehen aber ich
habe gesagt es geht darum maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die wirksam sind natürlich
reden wir leider auch von freiheits
einschränkungen an einer pandemie aber
so wenig wie möglich und so viel dass
wir das virus effektiv bekämpfen können
das haben wir getan 3g am arbeitsplatz
3g ihren willen v all diese dinge waren
gut und wirksam und richtig erweise
natürlich versuchen wir jetzt auch
freiheitseinschränkung wieder
zurückzunehmen sukzessive ist doch gar
keine frage wenn es die situation
ermögliche aber mir ist lieber maß und
mitte verhältnismäßigkeit als dass man
erst wieder in den kompletten lockdown
und jetzt komplette freiheit das passt
nicht zusammen haben sie mit politik
marketing tun bayern süd und wenig mit
die rosa holletzek alles nur politik
marketing sagt dr
es ist die beurteilung der situation und
herr dürr natürlich die fdp hat zu einem
zeitpunkt vom freedom day gesprochen wo
wir weit davon entfernt waren an einem
konkreten datum zu sagen der virus ist
weg das war unverantwortlich zu einem
zeitpunkt wo die intensivbetten voll war
es natürlich richtig die epidemische
notlage weiter zu fördern schleswig
holstein hat es jetzt gemacht mit einem
fdp-gesundheitsminister zum beispiel
also ich warne davor diese pauschale
täten wir brauchen eine beurteilung der
situation zum zeitpunkt wie sie sich
darstellt und wenn die diagnose da hat
lauterbach recht eine andere ist dann
muss auch die therapie eine andere sein
und nichts anderes tun wir jetzt und das
halte ich für verantwortungsvolle und
richtige politik